Hi everyone. Um thanks so much for
joining us. Uh we are here to talk about
our project security guidance as a
service. Um which is basically um how we
are democratizing security guidance
across different platforms.
Uh little bit about ourselves. Uh I'm
Chandrani. I work at uh Adobe as a
security engineer. I'm in this space for
about 10 years now.
>> Hi everyone, I'm Shri Dutag Gupta. I'm a
product security engineer at Adobe. Been
in the space for over 5 years.
[clears throat]
So uh let's talk a little bit about um
why we did this project, right? What
what is the gap that we felt and that
drove us to the project?
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh now we know like for scalability has
always been an issue when it comes to
providing guidance to developers right
like because uh for most of the
organizations the security to developer
ratio it's really low. So when it comes
to like you know giving one-on-one
guidance or whatever they're looking for
exact information. So it's it really
becomes a challenge. It really becomes a
bandwidth issue.
And then um like for most of the
companies there are u various security
process right if it's like an
established uh security program that you
have we have uh like design reviews we
have threat modeling like in the
beginning then we we have multiple
scanners running you know code scanners
and things like that and then on the
right you have the vulnerability
scanning and everything. So you are the
security researcher or partners they are
basically giving similar information but
on various different platforms right
and then finally uh fragmented
documentation. So this is um like
security champions ormemes they create
all these you know security docs and
whatn not what are the policy that um so
and so needs to follow what's the secret
storage that we need to follow but then
is it reaching the right person at the
right time right otherwise the
information becomes tell
so now AI uh with the evolution of AI
it's like a game changer right we all
are like on a rocket space uh rocket
space and
so basically it it understands the
natural language I we don't have to
write complex SQL queries and all that
to make it understand okay this is what
I want and uh [clears throat]
but then when we ask something to AI
like if I can ask very generic questions
right what are the authentication that I
need to follow right so it would
basically it would give you a very
generic answer that uh a generic
problems um solution to the problem it
would give you right it will not give
like what are your uh platform standards
what are the things that um you know
functions or methods that your company
is following and then finally
sorry uh there is always a risk of you
know hallucinated guidance right like
when um there is a lot of information
given to AI there is always a risk of
you know hallucinated guidance
>> [clears throat]
>> So sorry what we built here is uh
security bot or you can call it like a
security you know service. So basically
the idea is it will be platform
agnostic. So be it over you know slack
channel or be it in Jira tickets or
automated threat modeling guidance it
will give a seemingly same guidance
across all platform with various
different types of you know whatever the
inputs it's coming and u all these
guidances are come should come from a
common store right it should uh
everything should come from a
central guidance store and those should
have vetted information. So this was
basically the um the mission that u that
we started this project with.
So uh let's talk about the journey that
um we started this project this entire
pipeline or the security guidance as a
service that we are going that we are
talking about about one and a half years
before right and it did not really start
uh like how it exists today.
[clears throat] So obviously uh we
needed you know the or org specific
information uh bringing it to the people
at the right time. So we started with a
rag solution right we took a very
curated docs and uh we put it in the
vector store. So that is giving us a
very uh organization specific guidance
and initially it was u integrated into
the Jira ticket flow because that was
like the you know for Adobe
we have all the vulnerabilities then so
those have SLAs and everything we have
to meet. So it the first place that we
integrated was the Jira and almost at
the same time it was also integrated in
the slack workflow as well
[clears throat] because we felt like
okay people are also coming and asking
in you know whatever the same
information maybe they will not have
access to the Jira ticket. So they
should have um there should be somewhere
else also they they need to have the
same information
and then uh we soon realized like like I
was saying there are multiple processes
for security right there is threat
modeling uh there there are um ID
guidance coming up. So the same
information would basically be needed
for multiple different systems. So
should we build separate rags? Obviously
not right. So we need to build basically
a common vector store that would pro
provide information to all these systems
and it should be uh like platform
agnostic
and then we realized like initially when
we started uh with the dogs for you know
the vulnerability guidance the number of
dogs were really less. So even though we
had you know the um automation for
creating embeddings uh putting it in the
vector store for those we had automation
but then they were you know one-off
scripts and even before that we had to
take the um the the PDF content right
like like whatever would go behind the
vector store even whatever is will is in
justest we had to take that piece and
make it ready. So there was little bit
of manual uh work we would say that that
was uh involved even uh at this stage.
So we realized that we need something uh
that is called automated document docu
um injection pipeline right. So what it
would do is [clears throat] if I have an
URL it will automatically take the
content and put it in the vector store.
If there has been a change in the URL
that also it would you know scan through
u like time to time for the content
updates and it will put it in the vector
store
and then um obviously like uh whatever
the common vector store endpoints that
we built that is you know uh serviced in
multiple uh security process like we
have an automated uh threat modeling
guidance uh threat modeling uh platform
at Adobe so there also it's being served
test uh there is currently we have
developed uh in ID security guidance
through an MCP server so there also it
is providing the same solution
um uh we'd like to talk about the
document curation workflow how we built
it
uh uh so the initial thing is first we
started with the security champions or
you knowmemes whoever is creating the
dock and uh we imagined that all these
Whatever doc is going in the back end
that should exist as a metadata file in
a git repo right so the git repo will be
the source of truth. So once uh
basically someone gives that metadata
file it would these are some small
information that we are taking about
that you know the URL that we are going
to process. Once that is done uh we
quickly validate uh the metadata and do
a PR marge. Once that is done uh it goes
to an up uh upstream service which is a
downloader service. It's basically a
pubs sub model. So it listens to
[clears throat]
the uh git divs. So whenever it uh sees
like okay this particular metadata has a
difference so I need to take this
particular URL and take the content. Uh
there is also a chron job involved here
because whatever are the URLs that we
are saying uh that has already been
ingested. We are also you know time to
time checking like has there been any
update in that content
uh and then it goes to a
uh the upstream service which is the
ingesttor. This basically uh takes it
and puts it into the uh into the vector
store like uh generates embeddings and
puts it into into the vector store.
So once this is done we uh uh put the
message in a slack channel saying that
this document has been ingested and
after this we uh initiate we trigger a
eval workflow. So this eval workflow is
basically when we collect the metadata
we ask for a reference data set right
like um for the document that you are
giving what is a uh say three four
question and answers that you you can
say we can refer to as you know
reference or an ideal data set answers
and once these are ingested we would
test it against like how much
correctness what's the relevancy of the
you know answers and things like had.
So uh this is on one side like the
document injection pipeline. Uh now the
core architecture for the security
guidance uh service. So as I was talking
about it is servicing multiple different
platforms. So the input can come from
maybe a Jira ticket. So what's the
guidance for a vulnerability? Maybe it
can come from maybe a threat modeling
platform like uh what would be my
like these are the threats that have
been identified what would be the
recommendation it can come just from a
chatbot a very uh simple security
questions right so everything goes to an
AI orchestrator and then finally on the
right hand side uh we are initially uh
connecting to the vector store getting
the data uh actually even before that
based on the type of input We are
tweaking the system prompt a bit right
for each case and then uh we are also
after getting the response from the
vector store we are passing it to the
LLM for a curated uh JSON format like
however we u for each type it has been
configured and then uh we are logging
everything in langmmith. So uh basically
uh whatever the things are coming for uh
for traceability right and then for some
of these workflows we have online eval
also integrated uh that Shri can talk a
little bit more. Yeah. Awesome.
So demo time. We've looked into what all
of this looks like in architecture.
Let's see what this looks like in
practice.
So this is the first use case of a
security support chatbot. Um so this
basically one if you have any questions
that uh need to be answered as per the
company's policy and standard guidelines
like how do I do X at Adobe how do I
reach out to the security champion of
product Y. So for those kinds of
questions we have the chatbot. Uh again
in the back back end this is all the
same vector store which is pulling out
the information and providing it to you.
Next we have the threat remediation
guidance on the shift left side of uh
the SDLC. Um like Chandrani mentioned we
have uh an automated AI threat modeling
engine. So once it identifies the
threats it then makes a call to our
service and gets the Adobe specific
recommendations or security guidance to
mitigate those threats.
Then on the shift right side uh when we
have vulnerabilities how do we fix them?
We want to provide consistent guidance
across all stages of SDLC. So here the
vulnerability ticketing and triaging
workflow when they get uh a finding they
then again make a call to our service.
They provide us with all of the
vulnerability and exploit details. We
take that we provide uh the fixes and
also we provide what is the Adobe
specific recommendation. So how would
you go about how do we recommend you go
about fixing this vulnerability? One
important thing to note here is that we
not only provide the short-term fix but
we also provide long-term fixes. So what
if you're seeing not just one not just a
one-off vulnerability but multiple
vulnerabilities that uh belong to the
same class. uh so for that we provide
long-term fixes as well that can guide
the engineering teams on more secure by
default uh changes as needed
and then of course since the last year
everybody's been uh vibe coding and
using a lot of AI assistance to code uh
so that led us to think uh this is even
further left than threat modeling right
so how do we provide the same guidance
again to developers as they're in their
flow writing the code so that's where We
build the MCP server and let me actually
jump to the demo.
Okay.
I don't
Oops.
Okay. I'm sorry. This is really small uh
glitches but yeah. So this is a demo
wherein uh I'm in cursor and here we
have the MCP server which is called
Adobe security guidance. I apologize
this is all really small um but we have
this MCP server um and then it has a
tool called Adobe security guidance
which then makes a call. So at since we
are running into demo issues so I'll
just walk you through what this looks
like. So as you're writing code you can
then say okay how do I fix SQL injection
put that in your chat and then the
cursor this is cursor cursor agent but
this can work with any coding agent the
coding agent is connected to our MCP
server it recognizes that it is
connected to an Adobe security guidance
tool. So it then makes a call to the
tool, pulls the relevant security
guidance and then that guidance is uh
then formatted, pretty printed and then
it comes out um in the chat itself in an
NID experience. I really apologize. Uh I
don't know what's going on with the
demo, but
I think it's a network issue.
Oops. Okay.
Okay. I I really apologize about this
but we also wanted to show a similar
slack workflow wherein we had the same
query and uh basically the same query
whether you're asking from the IDE or
from the um from Slack or wherever
you're providing the same guidance so
irrespective of where you are in the
where you are in the SDLC process where
the developer is what time what
information they need we are providing
it to them as and when they need it.
Okay. So I will wrap up over here some
of the challenges and lessons learned.
So Chanani talked a little bit about
eval. One of the most important things
about building AI systems that you can
have in production is eval. It is time
consuming. It is manual but it is what
enables you to have things in production
and ensure high quality responses. Um
for us as well it was uh again time
consuming a very laborious task to have
all of the eval uh golden data set in
place. Uh but again that is one of the
most enabling factors about how we've
built this and how we've scaled this.
Second is dock freshness. Uh making sure
that we have the most up-to-date docs is
a challenge. Right now we have a shared
responsibility model wherein if we find
out through our workflows through our
eval workflows that uh a doc needs to be
updated we reach out to the document
owners. The other aspect is if document
owners have an update they come and
reach out to us so that we have the most
updated docs in our vector store. The PR
review uh aspect in the doc ingestion
workflow is also it can be a bottleneck
when we want to quickly and efficiently
ingest docs at scale but at the same
time this is a trade-off because this
aspect allows us to maintain the high
quality of documents that we are
ingesting and finally u this entire
field is evolving at a breakneck speed
so keeping up with the emerging tech has
been important as well when we built the
v1 one version of the vector store uh
the rag we did all of the processing by
ourselves like document chunking
vectorization everything at that time
LLMs couldn't even take multimodal input
from that now uh we have multiple vector
store vendors that you just upload files
and they take care of everything for you
so just evolving and keeping up to date
with what's happening in what's evolving
in the tech so that you are able to use
the latest greatest state-of-the-art as
you build these systems.
Um yeah, so key takeaways from our
session. Um AI is useful. AI boosts
productivity, but context is king. So
the more organization specific context
you're able to provide to these models,
the more useful you can make these
systems. We were able to build this
centralized guidance that has enabled us
to provide consistent and consistent
security. We've been a security guidance
and we've been able to democratize this.
So as a developer whenever wherever you
need it, you're able to get the same
consistent vetted guidance. And finally,
eval uh eval is what will turn your AI
experiments into production systems. Um,
with that, I want to make a quick shout
out to the team. This was certainly not
a twoperson project. Uh, we have an
entire team building all of this, plus
lots more. Uh, so I want to make a quick
shout out to the entire team. And with
that, oops, we are at time. And thank
you for joining us for our talk. And
yeah, we'll open up for questions.
All right, audience questions. I'll
start with one from Slack. Uh you talked
a little bit about uh developing sort of
threat models for your team, various
threat models and products like tell me
a little bit about the the threat models
that you built sort of and distributed
through this tool.
>> Yeah. So for the um automated threat
modeling there is a basically a separate
team who has developed that like uh the
wiki page needs to be in a se specific
format it parses that particular page
and gives out the threat. So where we
come in is when the threat has been
generated it uh gives out the Adobe
specific recommendations as well. So
there it integrates our platform and we
are able to provide uh that guidance.
Yeah.
>> Cool. Thank you.
One over here.
>> Thank you so much for your presentation.
So with a lot of these tools that we've
seen emerge and develop that are
shifting left into the IDE, how do you
guys how have you figured out a way to
enforce the use of those tools? So like
even your MCP uh server that's providing
recommendations around architecture, how
do you ensure there's consistent
configuration across all your developers
that are actually consuming that MCP?
>> Yeah. So there is actually another big
project going on within our team uh
wherein we have developed an extension
uh currently uh cursor is used the most
but then other ids are also coming in.
So the extension is for cursor. So once
you develop that extension all these MCP
configs uh cursor rules comes by default
once you sign in. So that's how
>> yeah to add to that we have done a lot
of road shows about building these
capabilities and sharing that with
developers and what we've found is that
when you make security zero calorie and
seamless for developers they will get on
board and they will want to do the right
thing. We have had engineering teams
come to us and say hey we love this we
want to use this. Uh so I think there's
the human aspect over there as well.
We've got one over here and I think
that'll
>> um so yeah following up on that question
have you tried also injecting these as
like agent rules and MD files or
treating these as skills and if so how
did that actually go?
>> Yeah. Um so yes we have added these as
rules MD files. We have been playing
around with skills as well. Again, the
extension is what we've been using to
roll these out to everybody so that once
you install the extension, you just have
it in your IDE.
We did some preliminary testing of these
security rules and skills. And in our
testing, we found that they were helpful
in reducing vulnerabilities and code by
a good 70% or so. Like even foundational
rules did really well.
Thank you so much.
>> Thanks. Thank you so much.